une voiture piégée a explosé devant une
caserne de la garde civile décembre 1987
saragosse en espagne
un attentat fait 11 morts dont cinq
enfants est rapidement un coupable
pointé du doigt le ter pour l'instant
personne n'a revendiqué l'attentât mais
pour les enquêteurs espagnols cela ne
fait aucun doute c'est l'oeuvre disait
ce matin le gouverneur de saragosse de
théa les trois lettres qui désignent les
séparatistes basques des séparatistes
basques qui multiplient les attentats en
espagne à cette époque là et parmi les
figures emblématiques de l'organisation
josu ternera il est d'ailleurs
soupçonnée par le gouvernement espagnol
d'avoir commandité cet attentat
deux ans plus tard alors en planque en
france il est arrêté par les
renseignements généraux français
il s'appelle recèle antonio
urrutikoetxea mais depuis toujours on le
surnomme route d'ernée est là il est
considéré comme le patron de
l'organisation séparatiste basque eta
il est jugé en 1989 pour association de
malfaiteurs mais n'est pas inquiété à
cette époque pour les attentats de
saragosse il sera emprisonné en france
jusqu'en 1996 aujourd'hui égoïste
étaient venus jusqu'à muret pour
soutenir son père à travers les murs de
la prison comme il l'a fait donc lors
décidé de ne pas aller le voir
1996 fin de sa peine en france
mais la police l'attend à la sortie de
prison et le transfert à la frontière
pour le remettre aux autorités
espagnoles ternira serait selon la
police espagnole
l'initiateur et le spécialiste des
attentats à la voiture piégée
il est considéré comme un dur de letea
l'espagne demande son extradition depuis
90 deux ans plus tard malgré son
incarcération en espagne il sera élu
député au parlement basque
et c'est là toute l'ambiguïté du
personnage terroristes pour certains
pour d'autres il est l'artisan de la
paix entre espagnols et indépendantistes
comme beaucoup de temps et sur l'île de
tasmanie
il est libéré en 2000 mais la justice
espagnole le convoque de nouveau alors
il entre dans la clandestinité
la cavale de josu ternera se termine en
mai 2010 neuf ans à voir
entre temps le thé a été dissoute
qu'importe les autorités espagnoles
tiennent à faire venir ternir as sur
leur territoire pour le juger dans la
sphère de l'attentât de saragosse
terroriste défenseur des accords de paix
cet homme à lui seul représente
l'ambiguïté de letea à voir comment
l'espagne va clôturer le chapitre au
théâtre avec le jugement de cette figure
emblématique
[Musique]